action here is illustrated by this
diagram to get to this point you're
going to go write ax + up Y right so
that's X comma Y but the other way to
locate this point is to have a radius
and then you rotate theta that angle to
get to that point either way you end up
at the same spot but the connection
between these variables is that x
squared plus y squared is equal to R
squared right from the Pythagorean
theorem and if you take the square root
of both sides you can see that R equals
the square root of x squared plus y
squared also we've got the tangent of
theta equals opposite over adjacent so
tangent of theta equals y over X and if
you take the tangent inverse of both
sides you can see that theta is equal to
the tangent inverse of Y over X
furthermore cosine of theta equals
adjacent over hypotenuse so let's write
that down
cosine of theta equals x over R and if
you multiply both sides by R you can see
that X is equal to R times the cosine of
theta and then the sine of theta is
equal to opposite over hypotenuse which
in this case is y over R and again if
you multiply both sides by R you can see
that Y is equal to R sine theta so we're
going to be using all these
relationships to convert from polar to
rectangular so in our first example
you've got R equals 8 sine theta so what
we want to do is want to get rid of the
R's and the Thetas we just want to end
up with X's and Y's when we're all done
so the first thing that I would do here
is multiply both sides by R if we do
that we get R squared equals 8 R sine
theta
now you might be saying hmm how did you
know how to do that part of its
experience but also part of its
recognizing that if I have an R sine
theta here what is that equal well you
can see that it's equal to Y so that
eliminates that theta there so we have
8y and we also know that R squared is
equal to x squared plus y squared so
let's do that substitution as well okay
so now when we get to this form we've
got the X's and Y's we've gotten rid of
the R's and the Thetas but what you
might recognize is that this is the
equation of a circle so you might want
to take it one step further and put it
into the standard form of the equation
of a circle so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to subtract the 8y
okay and set this to zero no what we're
gonna do is we're gonna complete the
square so we're going to take half of
negative 8 which is negative 4 negative
4 squared is 16 you want to add that 16
to both sides
now when you factor this you can see
you're getting Y minus 4 squared okay
and now it's in the standard form of the
equation of a circle the center is at 0
comma 4 and the radius is 4 so again the
goal is to get rid of ours and Thetas
end up with X's and y so let's go to
example 2 here so theta equals PI over 6
ok meaning the angle is a 30 degree
angle well what you can do on this
problem is you can take the tangent of
both sides
okay so tangent of theta is equal to the
tangent of PI over 6 now you know from
your unit circle okay that over here at
PI over 6 this is the coordinate square
root 3 over 2 comma 1/2 and the tangent
is the Y value over the x value so if
you take Y divided by X you get square
root 3 over 3
after you rationalize tangent of theta
you can see from our earlier discussion
there that's equal to Y divided by ax
and if we multiply both sides by X you
can see that y equals square root 3 over
3 X now this should make sense to us
because if we think about it in polar
form okay this is our polar graph paper
here right you can see that the angle PI
over 6 is going to be here here here
here and so on depending on what the
radius is and so you can see what we're
getting is we're getting a line when we
connect those points and that line has a
slope of square root 3 over 3 so that's
where this equation is coming from it's
like y equals MX plus B the slope the M
is square root 3 over 3 so both of these
equations represent the same line it's
just that this is import and this one
here is in rectangular so let's go to
example 3 now R equals 5 well we know
from previously here we talked about R
equals a square root of x squared plus y
squared so let's do that substitution
and then what you can do is you can
square both sides to get rid of the
square root so if we square both sides
we get x squared plus y squared equals
225 and you can see this is the equation
of a circle in rectangular form this is
the equation of a circle
in polar form same graph just two
different ways of writing it last
example again remember our goal is to
get rid of the R and theta and just get
X's and Y's secant of theta is actually
equal to the reciprocal of cosine okay
so that's 9 over cosine theta if we
multiply both sides by cosine theta we
get R cosine theta is equal to 9 and
what is our cosine theta equal well that
equals x so we've got x equals 9 so I
hope that helped you how to understand
how to convert from you know one form to
the to the other go ahead and review
this video if you need to subscribe to
the channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future math videos
I'll talk to you soon